it looks like chocolate chip but it
doesn't look appealing
do i have to eat it
hey i'm sarah beth and i'm a former
chick-fil-a employee
i'm brian and i used to work at
mcdonald's i'm marissa and i'm a former
employee of kfc
my name is diana flores and i'm a former
worker for wendy's
the perfect cookie is something that
tastes fresh
it has to be warm a little bit crispy
i wanted to see the chocolate like ooze
a little bit when i bite into it i want
it to be
soft i want it to melt my mouth
sometimes you get like a chunky piece
and that's
that's the good stuff right there i know
everybody's gonna like these cookies
from wendy's because they're
really delish it's my favorite and i bet
it'll be yours too
this is what i want in a cookie this
looks so good this has the big chocolate
chunks in it it's large
which is always a good thing i want to
get to this chocolate piece over here i
want that
it's like less of like a chip and more
of a chunk eat it with two hands it's so
big
it's not quite as soft as i would like i
guess this one just tastes a little bit
more like a classic chocolate chip
whoa that is so
good mmm i would eat that whole thing
right now
it's baked to perfection overall the
spirit of what a cookie should be in my
opinion is all there
so i give it a seven i'd say it's like a
7.
wow that's a 10 cookie right there if
that is a
10 10. i do want this one for later that
is
really good
the thing i love about the kfc cookies
is that it comes
with like so much freshness already like
packaged in there and so you have that
reliability that consistency
my mouth is watering already
what this looks like a fake cookie
the edge there's no chocolate
it tastes like vanilla like a vanilla
cookie the chocolate's all the way in
the middle
this one doesn't feel like it has a lot
of flavor nothing that's screaming like
hey grandma just baked me
i'm yours it's hard it could use a
little more chocolate chips i need more
chocolate chippage you know what i'm
saying
you know a good five is still a good
cookie
i would rank this as seven for the
effort
not a huge fan of this one let's go with
a four
[Music]
mcdonald's cookies are very soft they're
very chewy like they have the nice
little chunks of chocolate chip in there
and that's good
it's really like the perfect cookie
assuming you make it correctly
it looks like something that was like
freshly baked it's definitely like more
brown
i do love a thin crispy cookie i will
say so this is looking somewhat
promising to me
[Music]
oh do you hear that like crunch smells
nice
nope
i don't like this cookie i don't even
want to eat it
i think i was kind of nervous it was
going to be a little bit too crispy but
no it's not at all it definitely has
like a nice crunch to it like you can
hear when i was biting into it it's like
it's a thin crispy cookie and so i think
if that's what you're in the market for
this one's a good choice it's so
unappealing looking like
yeah i don't want to eat it so why would
you sell this is there one positive
thing to say about it
positive it looks like a cookie
that's it i would say i'm gonna give it
a seven half i mean it's no kfc so don't
get me wrong
but it's solid we're gonna just give
this one
a two and pretend that didn't happen if
i would rank this it would be a one
the chick-fil-a chocolate chip cookie is
good because it has chocolate chunks in
it
they're not skimping on the chocolate
people
and it's usually warm when you get it
and if it's not warm you better ask for
a warm one
because that is how they're the most
delicious this
looks like a hearty cookie it looks like
a giant chips ahoy cookie
presentation is just this
is a chocolate chip cookie when you look
at it you feel like there's so much
going on in there like you can just see
the
chunks of chocolate you can see kind of
like the texture
oh it's soft
[Music]
i like it i don't know if it's like
melty
i taste the chocolate it's really good
you can see it's smearing across the
chocolate
comes apart decently that's nice the
chocolate's like a little soft and
melted so that's a good sign
this you know what maybe i'm judging
this cookie before i actually get to
know it
let's give this a shot
[Music]
it's a little too crunchy for me not a
fan of that
i will give it credit the chocolate is
very melty and that's nice
just a little melty right there
wow there's like some dimension to the
cookie
and it's very buttery as well which i
love this is an amazing chocolate chip
cookie
this one not my favorite cookie um if i
had to rank it
i gave it like like a five i would rank
this cookie
a ton yeah i like it i think i'm gonna
give this one a 10.
i don't know what would make it better
it's like moist on the inside yeah
i'm gonna give it a 10.
[Music]
[Applause]
oh man the perfect chocolate chip cookie
chick-fil-a cookies
come on people they're so good i knew
we'd get here
um they really are amazing they're soft
and warm and yummy they got the chunks
in them
so if you haven't tried it you need to
go try it but um yeah
that will bless your life and it will be
my pleasure
[Music]
you